Salahuddin province this is the start of
the government's biggest attempt yet to
take back parts of northern Iraq now
controlled by Islamic state over 27,000
troops and Shiite militiamen are trying
to recapture territory seized by Islamic
state last summer including the
provincial capital of Tikrit it's the
hometown of former Iraqi president
Saddam Hussein and one of the biggest
cities under the group's control
territory captured by Islamic state is
shown here in red Iraqi forces are
pushing toward to Crete from three
directions the city is a gateway to
Baghdad just 130 kilometers south iraqi
prime minister haider al-abadi announced
the campaign on state television he's
urging security forces to protect
civilians during the operation yea
though I call upon you and all other
commanders to deal with citizens as well
our goal is to liberate people from the
oppression and terrorism of Islamic
state and half of Aden whoppin in Havana
we should protect the citizens and their
properties the security situation in
Iraq has been worsening since last june
now the government is bringing in the
heavy artillery and tanks to dislodge
Islamic state militants from their
self-proclaimed caliph it